hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots and I believe I believe we have
our guest here I believe we have our M
can you can you introduce him while pull
him up ladies and gentlemen he is a
legendary comic book artist he is host
of the trash cast not the Chicago Bulls
like intro what is
this
SK what's up man what's up guys how you
doing how you doing what are you eating
you're doing carnivore you said you're
doing
carnivore yeah I'm doing carnivore but
uh I'm also having some Lifesavers right
now carnivore that's very carnivore
that's a feel carnivore sort of negates
revenge of the cyst tonight is brought
to you by Lifesavers candy hey we're not
getting any of that money yeah come on
we're I get [__] [__] money man I
took an endorsement fellas I told
everybody I was going to be on the
biggest show on Rumble oh uh and I
immediately yeah you're on cat
show it's not us to me it's you guys as
far you know that big fan thanks for
finally coming on yeah man yeah we'
wanted you on for a while like the truth
of the matter is and you brought it up
it's like we always want to have guests
on but also we just doing the work to
get guest is like a thing and it's like
uh you know bro and then you like you
you line up a day and then I drive all
the way to this [__] house so I could
be in studio for a guest and then they
just don't oh we had bail on us cool
nice I thought you guys lived together I
had this impression that you guys like
rented out this awesome kind of uh
little Palace yeah it's like Entourage
yeah it's just like Entourage our turtle
and women hate
us
yeah it's not true it's not like
Entourage we can't get a Jewish agent
yeah I look I I more gay stuff I got to
I got to tell you and this is this is we
have a lot of guests on sometimes and we
have to pretend to know what they did
and be like oh yeah you're great it's
nice when you don't have to [__] you
don't have the [__] dude I read I
mean a lot of your [__] I own them in
a long box to tell you what a [__]
nerd I am okay the flash rebirth [__]
rules dude it does I I hated flash
rebirth that was like were saying we
liked it well you know what it's
probably the most popular thing that I
did um but I it wasn't good I I was
supposed to do blackest KN with Jeff
Johns I created both both of those
events I said we need to bring back
Barry Allen and then also let's run a
whole plague of [__] zombies on the
Green Lantern Corp and both of them
sounded great I did all the designs for
Blackest Night and then DC kind of said
you can choose one of those because
we're going to run both of those events
at the same time so I chose FL uh flash
rebirth because I figured I'd bring back
Barry Allen I I have some regrets but
you know what uh now that you've said
that it's your favorite thing yeah makes
me feel a little bit better I like vir
you read it too right yeah dude yeah
dude that was one of the uh when I was
like 145 it was like one of the first
Graphics I ever read like I dude [__]
it was phenomenal artwork that [__]
[__] ruled Ethan I'm sorry like he he
he marks out for that and you know the
the great part is is that now I've moved
on to bigger and better comic books
that's a pretty good comic bro that's a
good read oo I I will say this man
absorbent I've seen some of the the
pages you put out of uh cyberfrog like
on Twitter too and dude you your art is
[__] insane like you are a really
good artist it's very ey Bing look at
that thank you I appreciate that what
what 3D rendering model thing do you use
do you what do you use to R your
locations you know it's unbelievable uh
that uh was talking to another artist
today who uh was around in the
1990s back uh back in Rob lield Studio
during the Image Comics days and we were
laughing together about uh Isam and uh
you know [__] uh Eric July and what
he's doing because Glass House Studios
and no offense to Dave campiti and the
boys over there The Boys from Brazil
wink uh you know but what they do uh is
uh for a long time they have been like
pre packaging artwork they used to be
called um Light boox Studios because the
boys over at extreme Studios used to
feel like uh Glass House those Brazilian
guys would just light box and Trace like
other comic book creators work and they
were able to get stuff out real quick
Dave camped the guy who runs that studio
negotiates with American C like uh
Publishers and then just offers them
these Brazilian uh package Comics it is
unbelievable that Eric jly uh has turned
to them but it's also very funny it's
like reflective of kind of uh doing
Comics um you know on a budget just like
in the 1990s Comics that weren't very
successful um so it's it's amusing so
now what they're doing is they're using
3D assets instead of light boxing other
creators work uh they just go on there
and they just kind of run chat GPT to
create comic book scripts uh and then
use 3D assets and and they don't even
draw over them they're not even tracing
they're just placing them down under the
page now running a little filter over
them to make them look like line artwork
and calling it art and this is what you
know Eric jly apparently is into this is
what he did with the $3.7 million that
people gave him uh unreal egregious it
kind of reminds me of remember what
remember the X-Men cartoon growing up
when they just suddenly like hired a
bunch of Koreans oh yeah and they were
like I would just do it over there now
and the whole [__] show you're like
what happened looks terrible just went
completely
down yeah I think it's funny because you
know it this this could have this whole
this whole Eric jly thing and I
something could have been easily avoided
just by saying simple something like all
right I guess it's not for everybody you
know that's it and then all of this
would have just gone away but instead
taken he doubled down he got so [__]
angry you know he he he started flashing
out at anyone who said anything bad
about it calling him out you know
calling the cop telling people to run up
and then people show up and he just runs
away like I don't understand what he's
trying to do I read Isam and now
regardless of my views of him I I read
the whole thing and I was like I I don't
like this I don't want to read another
one and it was just saying that to him
would make it you don't get it you just
don't get how deep it is I know I know
fact the fact he got Riley taken down
too like he got Riley's Twitter taken
down and it's like Riley is not a guy to
be scared of like he's one of the nicest
guys yeah he's a goof I don't know you
see those videos of him like with giant
scissors I'm coming to cut your back
hair that's pretty scary that's pretty
that's some scary
he's such a [__] goofball one of the
things that you need to know in order to
get better at Art is you need to be able
to accept criticism you need to be able
to identify what good criticism is and
then learn to grow from it and you need
some humility now I'm somebody who's
been doing this for 30 years plus uh all
of my friends in comics gate are people
who've been doing this for decades and
decades and we still criticize each
other uh we still recognize that we're
not where we need to be and when
somebody offers us valid criticism and
sometimes it comes from people who hate
us you know it's like sometimes it comes
from people are like you know [__] Ethan
van skyver look at his art like that
arm's too long and it's like okay you
know like that's actually you got a
point there maybe I could fix that next
time around uh Eric reacted to valid
criticism from the great dick masteron
uh as though it was going to destroy his
entire world rather than help him and
since then like all all of this
everything that's happened to him which
has been very funny in my opinion has
all come from that one moment where like
his pride made it impossible for him to
just accept the fact that his first
comic book out of the gates wasn't a
masterpiece in fact it wasn't very good
at all uh and from there it's all kind
of gone downhill just the fact that he
doesn't have a sense of humor about
himself he's unable to laugh he's unable
to accept that he's not perfect all of
this has made him into uh this this kind
of huus has kind of led to a a pretty
precipitous downfall I'm enjoying the
hell out of it I love trash cast my
thing is just uh I I've liberated myself
from having to kind of excuse him or
apologize uh for him or stand by him
which I think everybody in the community
seems to want to do that's
the part that's the part that that we
were T that I've talked about a lot and
and a bunch of people talking about it's
like there is this cognitive dissonance
right with this this entire group this
entire group of people that they they
they made their careers critic izing
comic books criticizing Disney
criticizing everything and then the
moment somebody goes and does it to
somebody that they like quote unquote I
don't think they like him honestly want
my honest opinion I think a lot of this
has turned into just gross clout chasing
and that's probably why we're not as big
we could be bigger we but we can't like
I can't these guys gay keep man
conservatives Gaye keep each other so
bad I know I've seen it happen to you
guys you know I've seen it happen to
others but like this show honestly you
two guys are some of the funniest guys
on uh on on you know in YouTube on
YouTube on your on Rumble but uh you
know on in this space and I feel like
for some reason you know you're not on
these big shows you're not getting guest
appearances on some of these big uh you
know conservative YouTube channels why
why not we we haven't been very nice
either well it's not we're not nice
we're but we're honest no the problem is
that we're honest right like like
there's this like you know the amount of
people there a perfect example the
amount of people right now pretending
bencha and Tom McDonald song is good
like these people don't really believe
that but it's just matter of we got to
chase the clout we got to chase the
numbers we got to we have to believe it
look right now right now we have four we
almost we almost like 5,000 people
watching live right now watching right
now right now those numbers are better
than most of these other people that
have millions of people on Twitter but
it's because people don't like us people
don't like us cuz we're just [__]
honest when you're being a [__] nerd
you're a nerd look people criticize us
all the time who gives a [__] but that's
the issue that's what happened with the
Ari thing you see it happen a lot it's
happening with the Dom lucer stuff now
too which is people see the numbers and
go oh this guy could further my career
this guy this guy comes on my show he
could legitimize me and then you can't
honestly then critique anything if
you're looking at it through that lens
and that's the part where like look I'll
be honest with you like even if I
there's people that we like they'll be
like that's pretty [__] stupid why
did you do that you know well it's like
the Dom ler thing and like you know Tim
P's a good example and going back to
Eric July like Eric July is the best
example of his biggest sin was he took
dick Masterson more seriously than dick
Masterson takes dick Masterson yes
and the minute you do that you lose bro
like it's it's just that was the biggest
mistake like that's the issue a lot of
these people I think take themselves too
seriously and we never do it's like yeah
we don't care we're idiots like we
always people do not listen to us for
advice we just want to make you laugh
like we really don't care what you do
and your show sucks you're like it does
suck that's fine I'm far perfectly okay
with
thats off my back it kind of reminds me
of like when you know Jean CIS tried to
make a movie right when all he did was
criticize movies and that movie flopped
it was a terrible movie Nobody liked to
see it it's like I think with ar your
Ling just because maybe you might be
good at criticizing something doesn't
necessarily mean you're good at doing
that thing you know well here's the
thing I'm great at criticizing this [__]
and I'm great at doing it uh and this is
what scares these guys I think I think
this is one of the reasons why trash
cast right now is taking off in this
space uh listen it's so easy to sit back
and just say you know the Star Wars guys
the guy over a Lucas film they [__]
suck and Disney sucks and all this stuff
sucks Marvel sucks the worst Marvel
comic book right now the worst most woke
sjw comic book that Marvel is putting
out is Miles better than Isam and and
that is the reality and it it doesn't
it's just it's because those guys are
competent those people know how to make
comic books I know I work with actual
creative people for 30 years but do they
have a warehouse yeah do they have a
warehouse and are they FR they drone in
the warehouse
they have they work with diamond
distribution they they're the ones who
have the
warehouses like
Eric okay that's very Eric built a Eric
built a shipping service like he didn't
build a comic book company he built
that's what he is work for Jeff
Bezos well we'll see how this is a
creative industry these are people who
um you know who should be working on
learning how to tell stories this is
what dick Masterson told him this is
what I'm telling everybody yeah you know
you could you could sell a comic book
you could sell merch YouTuber merch uh
to uh to your audience for only so long
if you wanted to grow pass that and push
back I agree I think right now Hollywood
and in the comic book industry is
overtaken by woke messaging it's
disgusting uh I think there are more
people who are concerned about how they
look to each other uh rather than the
stories that they're creating from uh
other Generations they've squat they're
squatting on IPS that they purchased
from dead Geniuses and they're ruin
ruing them uh and so what is the answer
to that we can sit there and point the
finger and say fix it they can't fix it
these people have no idea they don't
know how to tell stories well uh you
know what neither do most of these
critics learn how to tell stories
stories are worth millions billions of
dollars a good story is worth billions
of dollars so learn how to tell a story
get it in paper put it you know get it
in print get it circulating out there
and that's how we're going to make a
difference if we are going to push back
against woke woke culture if that is uh
one of goals and that's one of my goals
um then that's how to do it uh and you
know responding with rage and fury to
basic story structure
criticism it's listen I don't know who
it's impressing it's not impressing
anyone in Hollywood it's it's not
impressing anyone in the comic book
industry and uh it certainly is an
impressing uh impressing me impress
someone hasn't seen lady Ballers yeah
that's right lady Ballers that wonderful
fantastic oh my God why are we doing
this why why do conservatives do this
why like it's like okay so you got a
chance to make a rap song why does it
have to be about conservative politics
because they're n because they're nerds
here's what it is here's what it is and
we bring this up this is the thing where
where people when people when you great
Point pushing back at the W stuff what
that means is we don't want any
political message shoved down our
goddamn throats you could have messages
we get it they're subtle great example I
always bring up is is is is Star Trek
right like the Next Generation
yeah sure it's a liberal show whatever
but they had you know their messages
were slide and they were in there wasn't
the down your throat I don't want to
hear any sides woke or or based opinion
just make a good story go back to
entertaining as I always say people want
to go back to I want to go back to the
1950s I want to go back to 1997 bro like
I don't even want to go back that far I
just want know 97 good
97 96 97 around there is perfect yeah I
mean the way you beat wokeness is simple
you make good stuff you make money and
then you just don't be woke yeah like I
shouldn't that be kind of simple
right all stories should be open to
interpretation by people who are reading
them it's like um you know you read uh
you watch Star Wars and Hey listen that
could be speaking to me as a
conservative or it could be speaking to
somebody else is a liberal you know all
it it depends on you know what you want
to interpret from it what you want to
take from it to me is is really really
good storytelling but I I think it's
really self-defeating that all of our
like efforts at lady Ballers like you
have the money to make a movie why can't
it be a movie that everybody is going to
think is funny that isn't so pointedly
on the nose about whatever you know uh
whatever we're complaining about in in
the culture right now it just be amazing
if somebody could write a song a
conservative could use their money to
write a song and make it a love song you
know what I mean like why not do that
something that everybody could enjoy and
then suddenly you've got a conservative
uh who's out there writing music and
getting top 40 hits um and everybody
likes it yeah and then suddenly that's
how to bust things open like write
things that everybody can appreciate
everybody can relate to 100% agreed we
we actually for our locals Rift lady
Ballers with with Dick and veto and it
was [__] hilarious but that was a lot
ofun it was 90% of that movie was
putting guys in dresses to own liberals
it was really weird the best part of the
movie was that this guy had like an
eight-year-old daughter in the whole
movie just hanging around in the men's
dressing room while they were dressing
in dresses and like they're just talking
all this trans stuff around this little
kid and I'm like what are we doing here
this what are we doing in this movie I
thought this is kind of against your
message isn't it yeah and and and that's
and that's what is and and I I think
that I agree with you just hating
something it doesn't make you good at
doing it and and and you need to
actually try to learn to build a good
story outside of your whatever your
political message is like you said basic
story structure right who's the
protagonist why do I like this dude why
do I hate this dude well that's why I I
can explain Isam to you it's very simple
he's a black guy and his superpowers is
he has no impulse control and he's
violent and he hits people oh that's his
superpower well that makes sense then I
get it he's a black guy who makes a
scene yeah that doesn't make him unique
the whole [__] comic could just take
place the whole comic could take place
in a Spirit Airlines
terminal that's now that's funny he
should be the cover should be him him
fighting in an airport yelling at a
[__] one of the desk
agents I like
that it'll be called ah so I'm late with
the flight weight veto's in the chat he
said he should fight his enemies in an
IHOP me you
[__] no man but I mean it's it's they
were so mad at you like that that little
nerd group that I I don't know what you
call them but that little that little
commune of people were were so mad at
you for not like just blindly standing
up for him because what he's an
independent like so what like oh
pronouns guy right pronouns oh yeah that
guy that guy yeah they get so mad and I
was like why are you mad at the guy like
this guy knows what he's doing he's
criticizing it because isn't that what
you want like dude if you're doing
something you would want somebody who
has like 30 years of experience to be
like hey man this is good this is bad
this will help whatever and that's a
great Point nobody the first thing that
if you listen to the first show merch
and I ever did before the rent it's
horrible it's [__] horrible you grow
you get better we were perfect on day
one no we weren't we were
terrible yeah I just think that you know
there's the the the group that you're
talking about is mostly concerned with
the appearance of success rather than
actual success right so it's like why
are you why are you preventing this
strong black man who makes us all look
not racist by his mere presence of being
here uh why why are you stopping him
from being successful well I mean
because um him making money doesn't mean
anything uh what we want to do if
anything here is is to be able to push
back and and be good at what we're doing
yeah so um that means having to learn
and we're already at this severe
disadvantage because you know this guy
has a huge audience there's a lot of
light on him and yet he has uh an
amazing amount of hubris and no Talent
yeah uh and it makes it makes all of us
look bad now I've got comics gate is my
kind of little group here and we're made
up uh almost entirely uh creatorwise of
creators who used to work for Marvel and
DC Graham Nolan created Bane lepry the
artist of Wonder Woman John me the
artist of cable Shane Davis creator of
deckstar your favorite your redlantern
kitty cat oh yeah tell him to follow me
I want to talk to him about cats yeah
mer so obsess with cat he loves cats he
loves cats see we know what we're doing
and and you know we know how to make
comic books and it it we don't have the
audience uh you know we don't have the
audience that he has that erai has yet
you know but hopefully we will dud trash
cast is blowing up dude I've been just
just looking at your numbers I've been
them every show they go up and up and up
and up yeah I mean like I I mean I know
your your wheelhouse is generally comics
and art but you're actually a good host
which is good you know what I mean like
most people are either good at one thing
and [__] at the other you know what I
mean like like like Eric jly was more
successful on YouTube and then you know
started doing Comics but I've like seen
your show and I'm like damn he's
actually a good host yeah see like Eric
jalai was good at like reading
libertarian books and repeating what
they say on it that's cool for him
that's cool that's awesome that he could
do that I wish I could just be black and
wear a meah hat and have a million
followers I mean eat chicken wings and
yell socialist on I I have this mask do
you want the mask give n cuz then I'd
have to put on a mega hat oh did your
promps not the mask it's the me hat it's
not Black Faces I have an issue with
it's wearing a [__] magah hat in
2024 put one on let's go I don't know I
don't know what you guys I think you're
you're both voting for Trump right no
I'm voting Democrat I'm a fullon
accelerationist now son of a bit see I
was I wasn't going to and then Tom
McDonald and Ben Shapiro made a song and
they won't shut up about Ethan Ethan
don't worry at the end we're probably G
to hold our nose and vote for Trump but
however I will say this MCH is
Right Tom McDonald and Ben Shapiro are
making it really hard they are I am
dangerously close to putting a d next to
my name we you already put a bunch in
your
mouth
got him I walked right into that go back
to what you're saying it's like when a
dog runs into a sliding glass
door cuz you're [__] and whatnot why does
my dog keep parking at my comic book no
look guys stop all right this is a
respectable artist we have on
here not anymore not anymore not anymore
he's like oh hello
comic think about this so if we're going
to do pandering right-wing [__] hear
me out on this I have idea for a comic
book I don't want I want Ethan to work
with it on me oh [__] here we go I hate
this hit me with the j6 comic book The
j6 Heroes Joe bigs breaks out of
jail get the gang back together again
you know that pandering horeshit would
make millions oh my God that would be so
good it would make millions and that's
what's dud what's his face with a big
wolf thing on his
head he looks like a comic book
character that'd be outstanding LEC guy
who could reach out to me' probably be
like I'm not doing that I'm not going to
do that le guy rules though um but that
that's that's a really good that's a
really good MCH has a does have an idea
for a cat comic and I think you should
pitch it right now no I don't have an
idea for I said I've been working with
Ray on a thing cuz he's been doing like
watercolor [__] I don't actually have
anything but we I do have he I embarrass
[__] don't throw me on the bus he has
a cat comic coming out I don't have a
cat comic I don't want your cat comic
but that stuff that I saw
that guy
Ray that is that is that stuff is
hilarious I love his watercol water this
Ray dude [__] rules like he's been
doing our he's just he just we we came
across and Mer has been talking longer
than I have but like he he had all he's
been making this little mini like in own
little Universe uh these little comic
books of us in there and they're so good
like the Dayton hypernova one was really
good uh he had this one with Alex Jones
that man it killed me Alex Jones was
paying hookers just so he could or
strippers just so he well same thing I
guess just so he could um just so just
so he could tell him about the New World
Order and MCH is working at the strip
club did you see this one this is yeah
I've seen this one this is literally
better than I saw him yeah this no it
really is it really is yeah man it
doesn't take much but I mean that sounds
great yeah you're right it's a low bar
uh there it is yeah he's really good man
like uh I was telling him like dude this
stuff is great why does my security
guard look like Steve C I don't I don't
know I don't know it is really good
though he does yeah he does f honestly
like that's when cuz he was just drawing
like panels with me and my cats and I'm
like that's [__] really good man and
I was like honestly let me think of
something to like come up with to give
you to do cuz he's just been doing it
blind shut
up what is it tell him so his superpower
is cat his superpower is cats you know
what you know what man this this is a
man I can't be messing they all out here
trolling me to go into my dead
grandparents spots remember that one
remember remember when Cemetery you mean
the graveyard you remember when I Eric
jly couldn't think of the word
grave he literally blanked out for a
good many like you can't be going to you
know people's dead grandparents
spots that's the kind of writing you
could expect fromong I [__] died when
he said that I thought I was going to
die
oh [__] man dude Ethan your show's been
blowing up by the way it's I I watch it
all the time so but I'm a [__] I
really appreciate that I watch your show
too actually I don't watch I watch the
clips I watch the and people who watch
YouTube should know like Roc Clips is a
really [__] it's it's scrumptious I I
love I love that channel and I love
checking in with you guys Dane hypernova
I love all that my favorite my favorite
has got to be Chris Cuomo though
whenever you guys te off on Chris comoo
it kills me did we clip the last one yet
cuz I was really proud of that it's
going to be up it's going to be up soon
I was really proud of the last quomo
segment that was fun it was good [__]
bread so good [__] bread I love that
man I I'm I've been obsessed with the
comoo brothers for years now I love B oh
man the day they remember when they had
those Q-tips those joke Q-tips that
[__] that's the day that I love them
more than anything that was the Q-tip
thing I don't get that joke see you guys
I'll show you you're going to love thisp
oh you're going to you're going to love
this you're going to love this the qtip
thing
is love this because you're going to
laugh for the rest of your life uh when
when he was still when he was still
working uh for CNN I here I this when he
was still working for CNN what oh is it
gone did they take it down well I guess
CNN do want anything to do with those
sex pests okay hey find it for me find
it for me so basically uh they were both
on explaining how you're supposed to get
you know test yourself for uh Co with
those Q-tips and they were he was making
fun of his brother's nose cuz it was a
big nose and he had a joke Q-tip made
and it's one of the cringiest segments
yeah it looked like he went to the magic
shop from peewee's big adventure and
bought like a a [__] a a gag Q-tip
did he take it down CNN might have yeah
cuz they hate him now yeah oh [__] poor
Chris Cuomo yeah poor Chris yeah poor I
found it I found it here it is it is
cool oh my God yep here it is that's the
thumbnail you had a video come out
before we go to break where you wanted
to encourage people to get tested and
some people are afraid it's going to
hurt so you had video of it that I want
to show the audience of you actually
getting tested oh it here it is okay so
here it is here you go he's up in Maine
all right here's the swap is it true
that this was the swab that the nurse
was actually using on you and that at
first he's so proud of the
your
nose hey yo Chris M always said you had
a big [__] nose mom said you know
Dad's you not dad's uh D I'm really
dad's only kid yeah
so I need him to explain the joke more I
need him to to go into it a little bit
more because on account of the fact big
cuz you got a big nose you got a big
that's why we have a gigantic Q-tip here
Ethan Ethan Ethan good news and dis
appeared that in scale this was swab
that was being I forgot there was two up
that double barrel shotgun that you have
mounted on the front of your you hear
that Andrew your your nose is so [__]
big that when the New York runs out of
Gaba goul they slice it off your [__]
face he literally goes that double
barrel shotgun you got strapped out the
front of your guinea [__] face what
we're on television dude we're not at
[__] dinner we're not eating Ma's
gravy both the disgrace comoo
Brothers oh [__] that's the end of the
show Ethan thank you for being on man
yeah trash cast check it out uh he's
still on YouTube that must be nice uh
cyber frog which you can get as well um
amazing art [__] on Indiegogo look up
cyberfrog and Indiegogo and and support
my Comics they're actually good really
appreciate
it one last question Ethan what was your
favorite part of ice
my favorite part of Isam was when uh
some big black guys throws Isam into the
air and he's sailing through the air and
the other way yra is flying because
she's fighting somebody else and they
Collide in midair it's the the best
me remember remember when uh Riley
showed up and taped money on his
warehouse and he was like I'm going to
shoot it you if you show up to my
business and then dick Masterson pointed
out doesn't Isam just beat people up at
their own private businesses isn't that
most of the he shows up to people's
private businesses and beats them
up oh thank you guys I appreciate it
you're awesome man thanks for fin coming
on you're welcome on whenever you want
bud okay all right app take it easy dude
see you later Ethan [__] rules like I
said check out Indiegogo cyber frog uh
is and then and of course trash cast as
well uh which he's been killing it must
be nice to be on YouTube yeah I'm going
to put his links in the chat man that
was that was [__] fun uh let
me